right here we've got a washing machine
we have got a wine cooler can fit six
bottles of Krug in there there's a nice
little espresso
there's your your washing area
toothbrush and so it's all there then
I'll see you finish your laundry we have
a nice little hideaway ironing boards
iron is right there fold this back up as
it then goes back in its place lots of
storage which is usually a big issue in
Hong Kong got a microwave you know how
those works and of course this is the
refrigerator let's have a look at the
shower and the toilet a glass door
really good fit so that the showerhead
behind me doesn't leak aim to here
I wouldn't recommend trying having
someone shower at the same time but I
guess it's possible a little bit tight
here a little bit tight but I suppose
you know you make do with what you get
the end of the day time to roll out the
bed have a look feel like I'm an Ikea
showroom here ah
but remember it's a bit of a puzzle
close the top step out of the way of the
bed not a square inch gets wasted here
there you go
okay now pull back in I'm going to put
the bed to bed as it were and let you
have a look at this place in your own
time without me blabbering on
it's all yours
[Music]